So the seventh and last principle of knowledge based AI agents in CS7637 is that
the architecture of knowledge based AI agents enables reasoning, learning, and
memory to support and constrain each other. Instead of building a theory of
reasoning or problem solving by itself or a theory of learning by itself or
a theory of memory by itself, we are trying to build unified theories,
theories where reasoning, learning, and memory coexist. Memory stores and
organizes knowledge. Learning acquires knowledge. Reasoning uses knowledge.
Knowledge is the glue between these three. One place that we saw reasoning,
learning, and memory coming together very well was in production systems.
When reasoning failed, an impasse was reached then. Memory provided
some episodic knowledge and a learning mechanism of chunking extracted a rule
from that episodic knowledge. And that rule broke the impulse and
reasoning could proceed a pace. This is a clear example where reasoning,
learning, and memory came together in a unified architecture. In logic,
memory, or the knowledge base, may begin with a set of axioms.
And those set of axioms decide what we can prove using that particular logic.
To look at the problem, conversely, depending upon the reasoning,
we need to put into the knowledge base, so that the reasoning can be supported.
Exploration of this learning was under the place. Where reasoning learning and
memory came together so well. Memory supplied us with the earlier precedents.
Reasoning led to the composition of this explanation which explained why this
instance was an example of a cup. This lead to learning
about the connections between this weirdest precedence to an explanation.
Here in the correcting mistakes was yet another example of, learning, reasoning,
and memory coming together. Where a failure occurred, when the agent used it's
previous knowledge, memory, to reason and identify the fault responsible for
the failure, reasoning, and then corrected that particular fault,
learning, in order to get the correct model. This knowledge based paradigm says
that we want to be able to reach unified, that connect reasoning, learning and
memory. And this also connects very well with human cognition, human cognition,
of course, has reasoning and learning and memory intertwined together. It is not
as if memory and human cognition works by itself or learning works by itself or
reasoning works by itself. You cannot divorce them from each other.